the rel do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie you ought to join us we could
use you I tried joining didn't work out
for me claim we're here for a reason
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones season
a prediction video I haven't made a
video about our favorite Clegane in
quite some time so today I want to talk
about Sandor Clegane who is also known
as the hound this character has been a
fan favorite for many years he has made
one of the biggest transformation since
he was first introduced and I think we
will continue to see him grow as a
person next season one thing I think
many of us are anxious to see is when
the hound and Arya Stark finally reunite
we have seen a number of different
characters team up over the course of
seven seasons but one of the very best
duo's was when Arya and the Hound were
travelling together since next season is
the final season we will see a lot of
characters reunite but I'll put this one
near the very top of the list for a few
different reasons the good thing is we
should not have to wait very long for
that to happen as of right now Arya
Stark is in Winterfell with her sister
Sansa and her brother bran the Hound is
currently with Jon Snow and Daenerys
Targaryen Sparty but they are on their
way to Winterfell as we speak and they
should arrive in the very first episode
of the a season I know me personally I
can't wait to see the look on Arya's
face when she realizes saint or Clegane
is still alive as we all know Arya Stark
used to hate him and she even left him
to die but when she started to train at
the house of black and white we found
out that Arya no longer wanted him dead
at one point in time he was on her list
but after they spent enough time
together
Arya started to realize who he truly was
and why he would do the things that he
did
I actually think Arya will be very happy
to see that the Hound is still alive and
it should be interesting to see how the
Hound reacts when he realizes just how
good of a fighter Arya has turned into
now that the night King is bringing his
entire army south you can almost
guarantee some of our favorite
characters will
died next season which kind of sucks but
the good thing is this has made almost
everyone team up with one another in
order to survive the winter characters
that used to hate each other will now be
fighting side-by-side which should be
very interesting to see the Hound and
Brienne of Tarth have basically already
buried the hatchet they know they both
have to put aside their past be for the
good of the realm
not to mention both of them now realise
they were both just trying to protect
Arya Stark I was only trying to protect
her those she's alive now that all of
these characters will be in Winterfell
next season there is a very good chance
that we can see them all fighting side
by side protecting one another even
though Brienne of Tarth nearly killed
the hound and Arya left him for dead we
could actually see the Hound save one of
their lives during the battle against
the army of the dead or vice versa Arya
Stark or Brienne could end up saving the
Hound that would be a crazy turn of
events it would be very similar to what
happened between the Hound and bran
right before the Battle of Blackwater
Bay these two men were ready to kill
each other but when the battle broke out
bran actually ended up saving him during
all the chaos if something like this
happened it would be a nice reminder
then maybe they need each other more
than they think
they would certainly get a hell of a lot
more done if they would work together
instead of as enemies we should also
continue to see that type of theme play
out for the remainder of the series most
of them already started to realize this
when they went out beyond the wall to
capture the white most of these men were
enemies at one time or another but now
that everyone's life hangs in the
balance it's time to put all that
[ __ ] aside and stick together you
know what they say the lone wolf dies
but the pack survives this goes for
everyone
now that the army of the Dead is
knocking on their backdoor they now have
to depend on one another to survive what
is coming their way now when it comes to
Sandor Clegane it seems as if he still
has a part to play I don't know what
matters I believe is that there's
something greater than us
and whatever it is it's got plans for
sandor clegane couldn't bad young and
old the things were fighting will
destroy them all alike you can still
help a lot more than you've harmed a
claw gang it's not too late for you the
Lord of Light or some other higher power
kept him alive for a very good reason I
happen to think he will step up and do
something big next season I think his
life was spared so that he could save
someone else we did see Thoris of Mayor
step in front of the bear to save him
when they were beyond the wall and the
Hound may repay that debt by doing that
for someone else next season could he do
something like this for Arya Stark or
even bringing of Tarth maybe the only
difference is I don't think he needs to
die in order to do this for some reason
I just have a feeling that he will
survive the whole series like I said in
a previous video before the Hound falls
under there cripples bastards and broken
things category these are the type of
characters I think make it until the
bitter end
they weren't expected to do much or even
make it very far in life when they were
first introduced but now the fate of the
entire realm depends on these Forgotten
soldiers the cripples bastards and
broken things are now on the front line
of defense against the night king they
have now become the most important
characters in the story and in my
opinion the Hound is one of those
characters regardless of what people
think of him as a person John is very
lucky to have him on his team because
the Hound is one of the greatest
fighters in Westeros in his battle
experience will shine at its brightest
next season now I know John will provide
everyone with dragonglass weapons before
the night king arrives but deep down I
am hoping that the Hound can somehow get
his hands on some Valyrian steel this is
the first time in the history of the
story that all of the Valyrian steel
weapons will be in the same place at the
same time like most things in this story
this is not a coincidence as of right
now Arya Stark has the Valyrian steel
dagger which was given to her by her
brother bran Stark she will continue to
use that weapon along with her sword
needle Brienne of Tarth still has
sir Valyrian steel sword Oathkeeper
which was given to her by Jaime
Lannister these precious weapons have
been passed around quite a few times
over the course of the series there are
a few other Valyrian steel swords that
could possibly change hands next season
and if they do hopefully the Hound is
able to use one before all the fighting
is done many people believe Jon Snow
will ride a dragon next season if Jon
what happened to ride Ragle he
technically would not need his sword
when he's flying around in the sky using
the dragon fire as his weapon he could
let someone else use his sword when he's
won the dragon he doesn't have to give
it away he can just let them use it when
he's on Ragle Samwell Tarly also has his
father's Valyrian steel sword Hart's
bane
now as we all know Sam is not a very
good fighter
sure he's killed a thenn before and he's
even killed a white Walker but he kind
of got lucky both times I'm assuming Sam
will spend most of his time with bran
stark next season these two characters
will attempt to find the answers to
defeating the night king now I will say
Sam could get lucky again and kill
another white Walker with Hart's Bane
but if he was smart which we all know he
is he should let a more experienced
fighter carry that sword into battle The
Hound could do a hell of a lot more
damage if he had that sword and everyone
knows this in a different video I said
Sam couldn't let Jorah Mormont use those
swords since Sam and Jorah have already
started to build a relationship with one
another if Sam would let someone else
carry the sword into battle he would
most likely choose someone he already
knows but there is always that outside
chance that the Hound could get it -
there is one other character on his way
to Winterfell who also happens to have a
Valyrian steel sword that is Jaime
Lannister who now has widow's wail the
other half a Ned Stark's sword ice Jaime
did take the sword into battle when he
had to fight against the Dothraki and
now he's bringing it with him to the
north now it's no secret Jaime is no
longer the badass that he once was in
fact he can barely defend himself even
when Jamie did have both of his hands he
still wasn't entirely sure that he could
beat the hound now that he is
handicapped he doesn't stand even the
slightest chance so maybe he shall let
the Hound use that sword instead a lot
more work could get done if the swords
were in the right hands like I said I
know there is plenty of dragonglass but
those are mostly daggers a swordsman
like the Hound
a sword in his hand not a dagger or
hammer give him a Valyrian steel sword
and you will see those white Walker
start dropping like flies Jaime
Lannister already gave one Valyrian
steel sword to a much better fighter and
I would not be surprised if he did it
again
not to mention Jaime knows that Valyrian
steel does not belong to him it belongs
in the north I have a pretty good
feeling that when it's all said and done
Jaime will do the right thing with that
second sword now assuming the knight
king is defeated there is still one
other thing that the Hound must do
before he can rest I have said it once
and I will say it again
before the series comes to an end we
need to see the ultimate showdown
between Sandor and Gregor Clegane this
was set up in the very first season of
the show and for some reason many people
believe that if that happens it's just
fanservice but I disagree it seems
pretty clear to me that this was always
meant to be a part of the hounds
character arc he even told his brother
during the meeting at the dragon pit
it's not how it ends for you brother you
know who's coming for you you've always
known
I happen to believe this is their
destiny the hatred the hound has for his
brother has kept him alive
hates that's good a thing as an e to
keep a person going better than most we
come across my brother maybe we can both
cross the name up a list
I reckoned you were gonna die by the
time I loaded you on the wagon but you
didn't and I reckon he died dozen more
times over the next few days but you
didn't what kept you going ate it would
be a crime against humanity if anyone
else but the Hound was the one to put
him out of his misery when the Hound is
finally able to face his brother one
last time he will deliver justice not
only to himself for what his brother had
done to him but also to all of the
people the mountain has tortured raped
and murdered over the past couple
decades he would also be bringing
justice to the rest of his family it
wasn't just the Hound who suffered his
brother's vicious attacks but almost
anyone he ever came across and what in
it Starks chapters we find out just how
sick and twisted the mountain really is
in Ned's chapter it says Ned seldom put
much stock in gossip but the things said
of Sir Gregor were more than ominous he
was soon to be married for the third
time and one heard the dark whisperings
about the deaths of his first two wives
it was said that his keep was a grim
place where servants disappeared
unaccountably and even the dogs were
afraid to enter the hall and there had
been a sister who died young under queer
circumstances and a fire that had
disfigured his brother in the hunting
accident that had killed their father
Gregor inherited to keep the gold in the
family estates his younger brother
Sandor had left the same day to take
service with the Lannisters as a sworn
sword and it was said that he had never
returned not even to visit the hounds
hatred runs deep for his brother not
just because he burned his face but also
because he killed their sister and
father even the damn dogs were afraid of
him it has to be the Hound who kills him
in my opinion it cannot be anyone else
this is one of the many reasons why I do
not think he will die when fighting
night king in his army because he needs
to live long enough to face his brother
one last time but like I said he doesn't
have to die fighting his brother either
there is one of the things that I think
the Hound can do and it also has
something to do with Sansa Arya and
Brienne of Tarth think of this as a
teaser for my next video I wanted to
make this one first as sort of a setup
for another prediction I have for Sandor
Clegane so make sure you tune in to my
next video to find out what that is I
think this is a good place to end the
video for now if you would like to enter
the giveaway for your chance to win
George RR Martin's new book fire and
blood click on the link that is in the
description of the video good luck and
thank you all for watching and I also
want to give a special thanks to
everyone supporting the channel on
patreon have a great day everyone I will
see you again very soon bye
[Music]
you